Michael Clarke our defense and security
analyst is with me now Michael we've
been reporting that troops have now left
the north of Ukraine what is the current
situation on the ground yeah absolutely
right they've been beaten they've gone
nobody there uh they've all gone back to
Belarus and to uh Russia itself to
re-equip and do something about the
losses that they've suffered which have
been fairly considerable about 20 of all
their forces have been
um uh incapacitated in one way or
another so they're now re-orientating
themselves to this battle in the
southeast
and that's what we understand that
that's where the race is almost on
between Ukraine and Russia to who can
get there first who can get their
equipment there first yeah it's it's a
sort of logistics race I mean the
Russians are going via Belgrade in
Russia to get back into the southeast
the Ukraine is going through their own
lines of communication
um but they've got heavy stuff to to
take which requires trains and heavy
trucks and also the ukrainians have got
the problem of getting the new equipment
that they're getting from the West
they've got to get it from the Polish
border towards Kiev and then down to the
south east and that doubles the distance
they've got about 1200 kilometers to go
so while the Russians are coming around
the outside of the clock the ukrainians
are moving inside the clock and there's
this race to get their heavy equipment
down for the battle in the Southeast
which is taking shape as we speak and we
had that terrible attack on the train
station what details are emerging from
that what can it tell us about perhaps
what's likely to come yeah well we now
know we can see more the um the missile
this is an ss21
um for certain
um it's not particularly accurate it's
quite old
um the we know the fact that so much of
it survived the impact shows that it
wasn't any high explosive in it it was a
cluster bomb so it it releases its
cluster bombs when it's still in the air
so what hits the ground is just
basically an empty missile and it's the
cluster bombs which are intended As
anti-personnel Weapons they just
intended against people it was the
cluster bombs that hit everybody in the
train station used in the civilian area
completely and utterly illegal
and we're hearing reports that there may
be an attack by air in Odessa and Odessa
is a really strategically important
place isn't it yes odessa's declared a
curfew uh starting today because they're
expecting more air attacks and the point
about Odessa is that although the
Russians are further away from Odessa
than they were a week ago they've been
pushed back the fact is they're
blockading Odessa with the Navy that's
in the Black Sea and the point about
Odessa it's one of the very few deep
water ports on the Black Sea it handles
a lot of stuff about 65 million tons of
of cargo a year it's fundamental to the
Ukrainian economy Ukraine provides about
a third of all the arable land in Europe
as a whole it's the breadbasket of the
world it is the leading exporter in the
world of Wheat and the the winter wheat
Harvest is waiting to be exported but
Odessa which is where it would go from
is blockaded so it's not only a disaster
to the Ukrainian economy but also to
Societies in the Middle East and Africa
who are waiting for that grain there's a
food crisis developing because Odessa is
blockaded and of course there are there
are voices in the west that says well
can't the Western navies sail into the
Black Sea challenge the Russians and
lift the blockade of Odessa well
militarily yes they could but it would
be an extraordinarily dangerous turn of
events